[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
the 100th episode extravaganza
spectacular there is that for to think
of it the 100th episode extravaganza
spectacular of Dear John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast for me and my brother
John answer your questions give me to be
surprised to bring you all the week's
news for both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John how are you doing on our 100th
episode I'm doing well I apologize for
taking a couple weeks off but as you
know Hank I have been signing my name
over and over again because I'm signing
two hundred thousand copies of my new
book turtles all the way down coming out
October 10th anywhere you buy books also
I wanted to let you know Hank there's a
new website it's a hot new website
everybody's going there some people say
it's the biggest new website to hit the
internet in many years and do you know
what the URL is what are the job
probably signed Turtles dot-com a guide
to getting a probably signed pre-order
of my book turtles all the way down
that's probably signed turtles calm
here's an amazing [ __ ] that's gonna
blow your mind okay no one had ever
attempted to register the website
probably signed Turtles com ever before
so John in like 10 years are you gonna
still be up keeping probably signed two
turtles calm and if so is it just gonna
be like we'll send you a turtle it may
or may not be signed by John Green yeah
no we're gonna change our business model
actually to probably sign two turtles
there's a 60% chance that you will get a
turtle in the mail signed by me on the
shell and then there's a 40% chance that
you're just getting a turtle well what
if this is like a 40% chance you get
nothing
that's just gambling I guess it's a
probably signed turtle but there's a 40%
chance that I'm just gonna steal your
money how are you Hank
I'm good right before I was doing this
as you know I'm very busy I have a lot
to do so right I hate it when people
complain about being busy I spend nine
hours a day signing my name over and
over again but do I complain about being
busy I wanna I've watched every second
of the Tour de France
I've III would are
you that I've participated more in the
Tour de France than some of the people
who are biking in the Tour de France I
have suffered with them Hank I have
crawled up the Pyrenees and the Alps
with them while signing my name over and
over again but do I whined about being
busy no John if you hadn't interrupted
me then I would have been able to make a
funny joke about how instead of being
busy I was watching competitive tag oh
my god I was also just watching
competitively I don't clearly browse the
same website probably sign Turtles calm
where you can find all kinds of
wonderful social media i competitive tag
is amazing yeah well I mean the thing is
it's it's it's not called competitive
tag of course because all tag is
competitive there's no non competitive
tag but there's this there's a sport and
it's like freerunning combined with tag
where these two fit individuals run at
each other and try to touch one of them
tries to not get touched
yeah and it's and and I think they have
like 15 seconds to actually because it
apparently is pretty hard to not get
touched and it is an amazing feat and I
watched like this jiff of it and then I
was like I need to watch lots of that
and luckily I was able to find some
videos of competitive tag tournaments
and you know John I think that the
sports we have right now are okay but I
think that they are of another era and
that we really do need ESP in the ocho
to come along and show us the sports
that like wait a second why aren't these
the sports I mean I certainly agree that
Meridius be in the Ocho because I don't
know how else we're gonna get third to
your English soccer onto American cable
I just I mean I just have to like I
don't like when I watch things like
competitive tag I'm like why even is
there baseball like I'm sure that's very
hurtful to all our baseball fan fans and
I just want to say to those fans we
support you a hundred percent speaking
of a hundred percent I did not prepare a
short poem for the day so can we move
right into questions from our listeners
yeah you got I do it's from Savannah I
just feel like this is one of those it's
a time-sensitive question because she
said it in three weeks ago and I feel
like if we wait any longer to answer it
Savannah's gonna be in a really tight
spot
Dear John and Hank how do I politely
tell a friend who is over at my house
that they need to go home now
much love Savannah I hope that the
friend is it like still there
I suspect they are is that what you're
imagining in my my experience it's very
difficult to tell someone who doesn't
know when it's time to leave that it's
time to leave yeah I mean there's all
these like like cute little signals what
am actually that well there's all these
cute little signals that people do
they're like oh they like stand up from
the thing and they start washing the
dishes and like clear clear signs no no
my my I have some like I don't know what
they are their relations of my wife
there are old people and when it is when
they feel that that feeling what they
say is well it's time to go to bed so
these people can go home that's a good
one I have a different strategy which is
that I start referencing media that I
think will communicate my message but
hopefully in a subtle way so for
instance I would say hey have you guys
seen that really great new movie get out
it's an amazing film it's funny it's
scary it's really surprisingly smart get
out is the name of the movie
another one that subliminal another one
that I've tried is hey do you remember
that Jack Nicholson movie the depart kid
that's a good one to use and then the
last one that I like to make sure to use
sometimes is there's a I say like I
don't know if you guys have ever read
the Sartre play no exit but it's a
really good play and in it there's no
way for people to get away from other
people and that turns out to be
literally hell okay I think this is I
think we've covered the ground my advice
start doing the dishes John's advice
just yell at them in the middle of
talking about other
things there's a great new HBO show
actually just wrapped up it's called the
leaved Dover's is it no it's called the
leftovers but I am NOT I am Willy your
makers um to get people out of my house
if necessary this question this next
question that we have comes from Ryan
John it's not actually Ryan it's just an
anonymous person hello dear Hank and
John I was watching your video on the
u.s. extraction with in Paris climate
agreement and I was wondering how all
this data on climate change is even
found most of my family denies that
climate change exists and they always
ask me that I can't answer them well
because I have no idea I just don't know
how the information is gathered
tumultuously confused in Texas named
emitted and replaced with Brian how do
we know Hank that climate change is real
what is climate science tell me more I
don't know anything about these things
well I mean how we know climate change
is real is a pretty it's a pretty broad
deep oh all over a question like we know
it from you know ecology we know it from
physics we know it from biology we know
it from from climate science which is
its own own thing there's a lot of
basically oftentimes with with things
like this you have a lot of different
phenomena explained by the same thing
and that is why there is so much
consensus around climate change but in
terms of their actual how like how the
data is collected I think that's a
really interesting question where you're
like well so it seems like the
temperatures are going up but how do we
know that like this is just like a bunch
of people with thermometers out there
being like well today it was 92 and and
then like like writing that down on a
piece of paper and tying it to a raven
and sending it off to the citadel no we
have a number of different ways that we
do that we have satellites that do it
and do it pretty well on a sort of like
broad everywhere scale they can tell how
warm the like and they can tell like how
warm different parts of the scar or of
the atmosphere are we also have weather
balloons that go up every single day
hundreds of them in America weather
balloons that shoot up through the
atmosphere and take readings all the way
through the atmosphere so we're not just
measuring that the temperature on on the
surface of the earth but also
through the atmosphere and then those
weather balloons pop and the things
follow the earth they break and we never
use them again and we do that hundreds
of times every day we also have of
course ground-based stations that have
been collecting temperature data for a
long long long long time so we know that
the earth is getting warmer but do we
know that humans are causing the earth
to get warmer and do we know that if the
projections about how warm the earth is
gonna get are correct well John that
wasn't Ryan's question first of all I
know but I'm trying to I'm trying to see
things from Ryan's family's perspective
yeah well that's the thing like that
like with conversations like these if
you want to be a climate scientist you
have to be a climate scientist so if in
order for me to answer those questions
like fully and accurately and deeply
like there are entire departments at
many universities that are dedicated to
those questions which is why it's like
well at a certain point maybe we trust
that you know not super well-paid people
who are doing this for a living like
it's their their job in their passion
the the consensus is yes climate change
is happening it's of course very
difficult to project precisely what the
earth is going to look like in 50 years
and how how warm the atmosphere will be
and watch which is why there's a range
of guesses but all of the guesses are
hotter than it is right now and the
upper level ones are pretty bad and
pretty scary which is why it would be
nice if we just sort of like agreed that
it was a problem and and do many of the
things we're already doing to help solve
for it which is create more efficient
vehicles create electric powered
vehicles start using more renewable
energy burn less and less and less and
less coal which everyone's doing now
because it's becoming less economically
viable to burn coal when natural gas is
more efficient and and increasingly easy
to get and also when renewables are
becoming more economically viable which
is very very exciting and and that like
isn't just great for like moving us
assuring us forward into having you know
billions of people on a planet and and
being able to sustain that planet but
also like you know making power less
expensive for people
and you know as these things get more
efficient and cheaper that's good for
everybody yeah I mean the only thing I'd
add to that Hank is that we have to if
you don't believe in expertise
you cannot navigate the world like if
you do not acknowledge and allow for
other people's expertise if you don't
allow for the expertise of physicists
you cannot get in a car and trust that
it will not crash yeah we we trust
experts all the time every day it is
only when what the experts say is
inconvenient to us that we suddenly find
ourselves saying but wait why are we
trusting the experts yes when explained
to me exactly how all data is collected
in this in this search and it you know
and when you know when you have an
incomplete picture
it's a suddenly really fun and feels
really easy to poke holes and yeah and
that that is a problem that we have
right now that is a big that I would
argue that is our biggest problem as a
species at the moment well I don't know
it's probably still malaria okay this
question comes from Ali who writes dear
John and Hank in a recent episode of the
podcast Hank made an offhand remark
about joshing your partner who was the
Josh for whom this term was coined and
what did he do to earn such notoriety
etymology and earthquakes Ali Hank I
know do you know which Josh you were
referring to I know I mean did I know
that be the term joshing is is not I
didn't make it up or anything you didn't
say it must be some Josh it was it was
probably some Josh but we also don't
know which Josh it was originally
referring to it was first used in 1845
but we do know that the word didn't
become popular until it was associated
with this American humors from the 19th
century Josh billings you ever heard of
him he was like sort of like the poor
man's Mark Twain and today even today he
is the poor man's Mark Twain but he is
responsible for a lot of quotes that we
hear although he never said them in like
quite
the pithy way that they are today
remembered I was one of those people
yeah so he did right but the wheel that
does the squeaking is the one that gets
the grease which is not quite the grease
exactly he's almost got there that's the
thing well when you're writing you
you're not like you're not trying to
create an aphorism like you're trying to
like it's as part of a larger document
didn't you say actually if you're Josh
billings you literally were trying to
create aphorisms he just wasn't quite he
wasn't quite there he's got another
great quote that you might recognize as
in a game of cards so in the game of
life we must play what is dealt to us
and the glory consists not so much in
winning as in playing a poor hand well
which is a beautiful quote but not quite
as good as play the hand play the cards
that you're dealt I love Josh billings I
this is my new favorite guy you should
make a video on on the things that he
said that got that got piss off ID and
became Joshy er so there is a Josh
billings quote that is one of my
favorite quotes of all time Hank that I
that is a proper pithy quote and I do
not know why it has not become like one
of the major American aphorisms because
it is just in my opinion so perfect
there is no revenge so complete as
forgiveness yeah that's yes totally
absolutely but not but but I understand
why it hasn't become a thing because
nobody wants to hear that I guess that's
true yeah what I hear that I'm playing
the hand I was dealt and I want to hear
that like that squeaky guy over there
keeps getting greased while nobody's
paying attention to me but what I don't
want to hear is forgive your enemies
[Laughter]
that's true it's also the part of the
gospel that gets quoted the least I find
I do you think we all kind of have a
Josh like it does everybody has a Josh
in their life who's a Josh sure they do
when you name your child Josh do you
just sort of have to expect oh you mean
like a josh is a Josh sure yeah like
Josh Sundquist is probably
ah sure uh no I feel like the josh is in
my life are not more or less funny than
any of the other people in fact I feel
like the biggest like Joshua in my life
is Chris waters and his name is Chris in
fact I would argue that we should call
it creasing
well apparently should call it marking
because Josh Billings was just the poor
man's Mark Twain that truly truly poor
here's another one the lion and the lamb
may possibly sometime lay down in this
world together for a few minutes but
when the lion comes to get up the lamb
will be missing almost there I mean you
need to distill it a little you're
getting there you my friend Josh
Billings are in need of an editor the
quality of John Green apparently or just
of time time will do is the best at a
time is the best editor so there's
there's your history of joshing
which reminds me Hank that today's
podcast is brought to you by Josh
billings Josh billings I think mostly
out of print these days but probably
nonetheless available online
my guess is yeah I mean the nice thing
is I feel like that's a was Josh
billings like pre copyright yes
everything is in the public domain so we
could potentially John you and I put out
like a collection of Josh billings work
and not have to pay anyone for it
that is correct it's just what the world
needs Hank and John bring you the
unedited work of Josh Billings
oh yeah I mean well also I gotta say
this guy's got really great hair on his
chin and head yeah he was he was a
beautiful man especially in terms of his
hair I say yeah he is a good-looking
dude well guess who's also brought to
you by climate science models climate
science models they're here they're here
get they've just get used to it
also this podcast is of course brought
to you by the wonderful new movie get
out
it's a rough it's great and you should
go see it at your house it is available
for rent at your home right now please
go there get out
and finally John this podcast is brought
to you by our 100th episode anniversary
actual sponsor it's not even a fake
sponsor John there's this service that I
don't know that you've heard about
they're not like they're not huge yet
yeah they haven't done a lot of podcast
sponsorships yeah I haven't done a lot
of sponsorships really anywhere I think
they're really trying to get their name
out there yeah it's just just new
company it's called Squarespace
Squarespace build it beautiful hey I
have to tell you you can go - not to put
promo inside your promo so that I can
from a while.i promo but right now you
can go to probably sign Turtles calm and
see an excellent example of a website
designed using Squarespace also also my
regular website John Green books and I
paid for those websites I really use
Squarespace it is an amazing service it
really is I have to say I want it I just
want to say two things first thanks to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
I I do think that Squarespace is a
really wonderful wonderful service it
allows you to build websites about
whatever you're interested in whether
it's how to get pre signed copies of
your book about the world or a
restaurant or whatever you're interested
in they have really great customer
service it is a great kind of all-in-one
platform where you don't ever have to
upgrade or update or change anything it
just works which is awesome and the
second thing I want to say is that
Squarespace has allowed for like this by
supporting creators directly it has like
allowed for this new economy in the
world of podcasts that I think has
helped podcasts grow bigger and more
diverse and interesting and so I'm
grateful to them you can get 10% off of
your first order at squarespace.com
slash dear John that is the website to
go to if you want to get 10% off
squarespace.com buy promo read ok ok
squarespace.com slash Dear John that's
deer Jo HN don't write deer anything
else it won't work if you want to use
deer Hank just squarespace.com / -
you're Hank that will also work I'm not
saying that we're gonna
out and we're gonna see who more people
do but there is two available you can go
to at squarespace.com slash do John or
you could go to Squarespace comm slashed
your Hank which is I think that it's
just easier to type I think that there's
there's too much right-hand action going
on with John I mean the great thing
about John is that you can make them
always right and with Hank you're like
getting onto every possible hand you got
you almost have to have a fifth hand to
play nice to mix it up it's nice to go
on both hands
I've always left my name because it is a
right hand typed name which I've always
been grateful to my parents for but
anyway you can experience the joy of
typing my name by going to Squarespace
comm slash Dear John and getting 10% off
your first Squarespace order thanks
again to Squarespace for being our
first-ever actual sponsor did you know
John that the that there is one that
what the longest word you can type with
just one hand is I do Oh what is it liar
you can't just say I do it not know and
start googling it's rupture worked you
google her wait that's not even right
that's not even right gosh dang it
Google well I mean it really it depends
on what you count a word after cataracts
apparently is ik is a word after
cataracts is not a word that's ludicrous
oh I agree after after cataracts is
clearly two words cataracts is an
impressively long one though whenever I
type the word garage which I do often
when I'm opening up garage Vantage is
how I record this podcast I'm always
like woohoo didn't need that right hand
at all and it's a surprisingly good
feeling but but but using just the right
hand for me for some reason feels really
wrong which is why you should use
squarespace.com / - your Hank Wow
I mean I appreciate you I appreciate
your commitment to to the URL I'm
surprised that you can spell monopoly
with one hand that's a shock to me well
yeah there aren't there are more there
are longer ones with the left hand than
with the right hand which is interesting
I'm not really sure what that's about
yeah teeter totter all one one hand
although all the left-hand oh really
yeah what about the O in teeter-totter
you know John I think maybe your
keyboard looks a little different from
mine oh really is your is your over
there on the left is it is it where my Q
is I think you might be looking at the Q
and seeing a no yeah no that's that's
where my o is I switched it because I
was like the cute debt doesn't belong
there
aggregating stewardesses Oh
stewardesses I want to tell you my gosh
another great no our desk
oh yeah that's crazy rupture what was
this Tesar Tesoro decades
tesara decades that's what decades is a
very that's a very mart in my opinion an
extremely marginal word it's a group of
14 right but I mean if we're talking
about words that everybody uses in
regular conversation well is that like a
dozen like it like it's like if a dozen
but with 14 a group like there are
Tesoro decades and Tesoro decades of
them yeah like I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know what I think we should
move on from this bit thank Squarespace
all right okay here's another question
it comes from Emily who asks dear Hank
and John I work at a Jimmy John's and
recently while I was cleaning tables by
our big front windows I watched a bug
Ram its little body to the glass for the
outside several times before just
landing and chilling on the window for a
while this makes me wonder do bugs
understand glass our window is a
constant perplexing struggle in their
daily bug lives sandwiches and spiders
Emily I will have got at least the bug
was on the outside of the Jimmy John's
yeah that's I have a theory dr. sink can
I tell you my food guy sure oh my gosh
you have a theory about it what a shock
well as you know I'm not a scientist but
I am a person who makes statements with
a lot of confidence regardless of
whether they're correct yep yeah me too
I don't think that bugs understand what
glass is I don't think they get the idea
of glass but I think that there is
enough reflection off the glass almost
always that they recognize that it is a
barrier of some kind I think that they
can and cannot so I
there are some types of glass that bugs
will see better and probably the glass
of the doobie Jones is UV coated and
bugs I think I think can mostly see in
the UV range and so we'll see that there
that there is something there it won't
look totally transparent to them like it
looks to us so probably probably but at
the same time like a bugs not gonna do
that to a wall it's not just kind of
like bang bang bang bang against a wall
right right well unless it really I
guess it's because there's light that it
wants to get to I mean like in our house
for instance at night there's always
like a wall of moths against the the
windows trying to get inside because
there's light inside and they think it's
the moon or whatever it bugs are not
very smart and I often think about like
III anthropomorphize them a little bit
and I think like man it must be so weird
being a bug and like going around the
human world and just being like why are
these people built all this crap why do
they need all of this support their
little love and they put the lights
inside a box that I can't get through
why did I do that sure look like also
like why have they create why do they
live in that much space yeah like why
have they made that much inside when
like you only need a tiny amount of
inside because it in a bugs opinion like
outside is so enjoyable I just think we
must look so weird to bugs I mean I
think we would look weird to bugs if
bugs thought about anything the thing I
gotta say to Emily as as a person who
understands the tiniest amount about bug
behavior bugs don't understand windows
because bugs don't understand anything
understanding is a pretty high high
order thing you know what I've been
thinking about recently Hank no it's
slightly related to this but we're gonna
get off it a little bit it's really
really hard to go from like a
single-celled life to multicellular life
and then of course it's like hard to go
like the layers of complexity increase
and everything but I actually think that
if we went extinct I'm not an
evolutionary biologist as you might know
but I actually I feel like if we went
extinct it wouldn't be
that long until a really smart species
came along again possibly even smarter
than us because I don't think we've said
a particularly high bar I I don't think
it would be that long because I think
like given that life tends to grow more
complex and more diverse over time once
we extinct if I ourselves which as you
know I think is like a 1,000 to 2,000
year event probably but if we could make
it past that I think we can be good for
a while anyway
I just think that like it's the hard
part we already did by getting to
multicellular life yeah no I think you
are absolutely correct I don't know that
it would be fast in terms of how we
think about fast but we would definitely
be fast and know millions of years like
fast in in terms of evolutionary biology
like there there was like a billion
years where it was just single-celled
life and then from dinosaurs to now is
like 65 million the the right and and
also there are a lot of other smart
animals on the planet right now we learn
over and over again and that's things
that are similar to us like you know
monkeys but also a little bit different
from us like dolphins and also very very
different from us like just like
cephalopods like we are all we
continuously shocked by how smart
octopuses are so yeah I think you mean
ah calamities but I oh no I think you
mean I'm gonna stick with my original
pronunciation octopi I just I saying
that that is correct and also octopod
ease is correct so that's just the way
that I pronounce it it's like Giffen
Jeff the actually according to the
internet only you are correct I don't
care at all I don't think that I'm about
I'm not gonna not gonna fight that one
really but I'm glad you looked it up
yeah that yeah I think like that that
leap that we made is a big leap but I
don't think that we would be the last
species to make it if we stopped
existing I think that it would be very
hard to have humans stop existing
completely
I mean it's not gonna be that hard I
think it'd be very easy to have most
humans stop existing and for a lot of
civilization to stop existing a lot of
technology to stop existing but yeah I
mean I think it'd be pretty hard to get
rid of all people we're we're well we
are just good at surviving I mean you
say that about a species that's been
around for 250,000 years we're one of
the least successful extant species in
the world in terms of in terms of years
on the planet but in terms of speed with
which our biomass and biomass that we
control it has increased we are the most
successful species on the planet yeah
but let me ask you a question Hank if
you're a youtuber would you rather be
the kind of person who built like a
massive audience really really quickly
or would you rather be the kind of
person who like had slow and steady
growth over years and years you're right
John I would rather be you know wheezy
waiter
if then you know like somebody who says
dab before dabbing yeah to each their
own John no no I I'm just saying like I
think that if we're a species that has
grown quickly that may just mean that
the other side of the mountain will also
be steep yeah I just think that I think
that getting to zero is gonna that's
gonna flatten out a lot but that's just
me and that's just where I'm at John man
I think we could get to zero very very
quickly you know what the funny thing is
we're never gonna get to settle this bet
because if I'm right I won't even be
around to gloat and if you're right you
will be so I probably won't be we'll
probably both won't make it but I
thought of friends who are like
survivalists you know they have they
like have bow and arrows and no no
survivalists are not gonna do any better
than the rest of us when this stuff
comes down because you can't be a
survivalist from like the super cholera
that kills us all right sure I mean I
guess if it's super cholera I hope it's
not super cholera John that doesn't
sound like any fun at all well what are
you hoping it is I'm hoping
it's nothing I mean I what are you
rooting for nuclear apocalypse there's a
huge explosion of the Yellowstone
Volcano what do you think it like my
imagining of the apocalypse is just sort
of a breaking down of systems so like
the idea that it all happens at once to
me doesn't really work it's it's like
suddenly like the trucks with the
gasoline stop coming and then when the
trucks with the gasoline to stop coming
then the trucks with the food stop
coming and then when the trucks and the
food stop coming people start stabbing
each other right okay but I don't know
that I totally agree with that by the
way I think that I I don't I don't buy
the nasty brutish and short vision of
the the state of nature but my question
is what causes the the trucks to stop
coming and the answer is almost
invariably super cholera like some some
disease that is ravaging people and that
does not care whether you own a bow and
arrow or not mm-hmm do you disagree a
Bijan if we're gonna like we have I
think on dear Hank and John done a
fairly good job of covering possible
apocalypse scenarios I just don't feel
like we need to talk about it all right
I will say the last thing I want to say
on this topic though Hank is that you
have convinced me to become a person who
has a large amount of water sitting in
the basement hey have a supply of water
sitting in the basement so that I can
watch the world burn for two weeks
before I go and join the zombie hordes I
will say that the US government suggests
that you have three three days worth of
water and food for every member of your
household and I think that's a really
good and not crazy and not doomsday
prepper kind of thing to do and if you
want to up that to a week or two that's
also fine it's not it's not a huge
square footage commitment in in your
house I would assume but but yeah I
think that like what I think about those
that three-day supply I'm like you know
like why the US government wants that is
because it takes three days to like
really mount a significant emergency
response and if in those in those three
days people are more or less taken care
of that makes everyone's job so much
easier
and I really like I honestly do think
that everyone should have three days
supply of food and water for every
member of their household so man I think
Squarespace would be so psyched to know
that they're sponsoring this weird
doomsday podcast yeah it's so
appropriate on the 100th episode of dear
Hank and John we finally go deep with
our doomsday apocalypse scenarios and
how much water to have yeah alright I
got I've got to go home and make sure I
got 12 days of water per the US
government suggestion
free let's get to another question from
waivers Hank yes good good this question
comes from Jenny who asks dear Hank and
John the school year is coming to an end
and I'm full of the usual feelings of
excitement sorrow and nostalgia this
year something else I have a teacher who
I really like and will really miss next
year and I want her to know how much I
enjoyed the classes I took with her on
the last day I'll be in her class last
so it will be a nice end but I don't
know how I know I'll feel awkward doing
it but I really want to how do I tell my
teacher in a meaningful way how much I
enjoyed her class reading in history
Jenny really sorry Jenny that this
answer came after the school year ended
but yeah great work John and Hank but
for everybody else who this might help
and also maybe Jenny could do something
retrospectively I mean here's the thing
you always feel awkward saying that
stuff or it makes you uncomfortable it
makes you nervous you think you're gonna
make an idiot out of yourself
but the thing that your teacher probably
wants more than anything is to know that
she has made a difference in the lives
of her students and to tell her that is
not an inconvenience to her it is a gift
to her yeah III mean I my guess is that
a card will be literally a million times
more than she's ever gotten before and
that's well not literally a million
times no in right infinite a million a
million cards might be a million times
more no I don't know that I don't know
that the the listener can necessarily
afford a million car
nor in fact am i completely convinced
that the teacher would like to receive
them I mean Hank you throw around big
numbers but you don't know what they're
at what they actually mean until you
sign 200,000 sheets of paper you don't
know how many a million is I would only
be one fifth of the way to so a million
cards what I what I meant to say what
what I was intending to get across is
that in general it will be infinitely
more because she will never have even
received a card before and like that
like I certainly never thought deeply or
hard enough to thank my teacher in a in
any way at the end of the school year
and so taking the time to do that
and to just like like write some stuff
in the car to just hand if you don't
have to like be face-to-face and all
like weird and uncomfortable about it
cuz that's probably gonna be weird and
uncomfortable though if you could pull
it off a hundred percent do it but it's
easier to write some words down in a
card and hand it to them and say thank
you so much or send it to them since
maybe you've missed your opportunity to
hand it in the last day of class but
yeah and I know I've received a few of
those cards over the years and I have to
say I've kept them all and sometimes I
still read them and they make me cry and
and it sounds like this teacher has had
a much more meaningful impact on your
life and I've had on anybody so yeah I
think you should I absolutely think you
should say something and I also think
that you should put it in a card I agree
with Hank 100% but don't put it in a
million cards don't put it in a million
cards and if you want to you could also
do any cut like you could give them a
book that you really love you could give
them you know a bumper sticker like any
old thing is gonna feel it is a nice
thing you don't have to like you don't
have to overthink this next question
comes from Millicent who writes Dear
John and Hank next semester I have class
with a writer I've loved for years I
read her first book of short stories in
2010 when they came out and now she
teaches at my college and I'm taking
screenwriting with her the only words
I've said to her face so far are oh my
god this is so embarrassing I love you
I've interacted with her several times
since this moment but I've never managed
to breathe long enough to speak oh boy
how do I learn to chill always your
friend Millicent PS that's how Hemingway
signed off his
although he wasn't always your friend so
that's a curious irony I guess in
Hemingway's life so Hank this is a field
in which we have a little bit of
experience on both sides of the coin
definitely have I told my meal gaming
story on the podcast before John
probably but tell it again I was
backstage at the one-year anniversary of
the recent releases The Fault in Our
Stars where we did our Carnegie Hall
Show yep and and Neil Gaiman came to do
a dramatic reading of a scene and and
there were a bunch of other great people
there Kim you Dawson and John Danielle
and and Hannah and Grace were there we
had a fantastic time and I was signing
posters backstage Neil Gaiman came and
sat down next to me and I was like
freaking out was freaking out how do %
freaking out and and he like told me a
whole story about how the first time we
met and I'm using air quotes because at
that point like I was just in a his
signing line and and I had him like
deliver a message to John and say good
morning John and it showed there
breathing the heated in Montana and he
signed my book and he did this whole
story about how like he told me this
whole thing was amazing it was like like
heartfelt and like like about how just
before that show his dog had died and
that there like that had been a really
important show for him till I keep
working and moving and doing stuff and
like like in feeding off of the the
positive feelings that his community and
audience had for him and and I just sat
there and I was like uh-huh uh-huh
yep yep uh-huh
and I could I couldn't say anything I
couldn't do anything I couldn't talk
about any of the dogs that I've known
that have died I couldn't I could not
relate at all or speak in sentences to
him and still have never ever been able
to like have a normal conversation and I
felt like the kind of like I feel like
that super sucks for Neil right right
yeah no I think it does I mean I what I
think is weird is that some people I
really really admire
I can talk to like normal people and
some people I can't and it doesn't have
anything to do with them you know it is
entirely about me like when I see patch
Rothfuss or talk to Patrick Rothfuss on
the phone I love his work I think he is
an actual genius and I can talk to him
like a normal person or when I talked to
Jacqueline Woodson who I think is you
know like one of the great geniuses of
children's book writing ever I can talk
to her like a normal person
when I met Sherman Alexie no dice it
just did not I did anything I just I
just couldn't I couldn't like tried like
three different times and then I was
like you know what time to quit like the
if I've learned one thing from if you
can't keep your chill it's cut your
losses I this year at VidCon we met the
cast of pitch perfect - and I totally
weird it out on them you don't you went
a little too hard you did come a little
too hard because you were like guys I
know this is an unpopular opinion but I
like pitch perfect - better than pitch
perfect one and they were like yeah
thanks that's cool we like - and you're
like yeah no it's great and I was like
that's enough Hank that's enough I'm not
going all the way because you're not
telling them what I said because I'm not
also going to tell them what I said yeah
I'm not gonna repeat everything because
it was way you did you did you did go a
little too far but I understand it like
it's exciting to meet people whose work
you admire and who you've probably never
thought you were gonna get to meet and
especially to take a class with them as
exciting but if you're gonna the thing
is you can't follow that cut your losses
advice if you're gonna be in a class
with them where they're giving you a
grade you're gonna have to like John's
advices like skip class drop out go away
cancel do not go to that class find a
different class to attend yeah no I I
don't the right advice is that it event
I suspect that eventually you pretty
quickly probably when you have this
person as a teacher you will realize
that they are just a person and even if
they're one of those extremely
charismatic like for instance my college
writing classes were taught by this guy
PF Kluge who I really admired his
writing and I definitely was super
intimidated by him and part of the
reason I was intimidated by him was
because he was this
larger than life presents you know the
way he talked the way you couldn't wear
hats in his class or chew gum the way
you had like the way he would notice the
moment you weren't paying attention he
was one of those teachers you know and
but eventually you start to realize that
these people are people that they're
just people and that the work that they
do isn't made by some like genius that's
separate from the rest of humanity it's
it's made from within humanity and I
think if you can acknowledge that in
someone then it becomes a lot easier to
to hang out with them yeah
and I'll also say that I I at Eckerd
where I went to I did my undergrad Elie
Wiesel taught class and Wow I always was
like I'm not and of course like it was
like most people didn't get into it who
wanted to take it but I never even tried
because I was like that's too scary for
me to try and yeah take that class and
now of course I regret that tremendously
so take the opportunities do you though
I don't know like I you know I Toni
Morrison teaches a couple classes at
Princeton I think she still does and I
remember my best friend from high school
went to Princeton and he was like man I
can't do it I can't I can't I can't do
it I can't I can't handle like a and I
totally get that like I couldn't handle
uh-huh learning from Toni Morris it
would be too it would be too cool like I
would not be able to ever recover my
chill I don't think so I I understand I
definitely understand the problem but
yeah it's funny I mean I've had a there
have been a few times in my life and I
know this has happened to you Hank
because I've seen it happen where like
people ran up to me like screaming and
like I don't know what to do I don't
know how to handle being screamed at
even if it's very positive screaming
yeah yeah I know it's it's a weird thing
and like it's it's something that nobody
wants to complain about of course
because like it's wonderful and it's
it's like a side effect of this great
thing having happened to you which is
having a community having an audience
and and and and having people who want
to consume the things that you create
but but I do like I know a lot of my
friends like dread going on flights
because they know that they're like when
they're gonna be in a large like an
airport with a bunch of people like
there's kind of like it's not gonna just
be like like you know six o'clock in the
morning doing this thing that you don't
really want to do but it's gonna be
doing it with a bunch of people who want
something from you and I know like
people who overmedicate themselves
because of that and and it like upsets
me that that's like you know that that
is sometimes their reaction to that and
I yeah it bums bums me out yeah it is a
real thing it is it is a real thing but
it is also obviously like a an extremely
privileged right problem there's a
recent Jaden animations video that's
that touches on this actually that I
thought was just brilliant like it talks
about it without ever seeming ungrateful
yeah and it's really really good so I
would also watch that video maybe for a
little bit of insight into what your
teacher might be experiencing in that
situation Hank we have to get to us some
comments and some some Corrections one
very important correction that was sent
in 652 billion times ok what did we do
all right we said that the United States
has the best barbecue in the world well
and a lot of people in Australia took
that extremely personally because
apparently Australia is the world's
leading barbecuing nation among all of
the nations in the southern hemisphere
on the continent of Australia I'm yeah I
just I mean I understand that throwing
another shrimp on the barbie is
apparently one of the one of the things
that we know about Australians just yes
I be by being a human being in America
for some reason but America has the men
I think mostly because of Outback
Steakhouse is that what it's from
I don't know well the important thing is
that America has the best barbecue like
yeah I and if somebody's on another
country said that about their country I
would be offended and it's ok
for you to be offended because like
Korean barbecue or Australian barbecue
or Malaysian barbecue you think is
better American barbecue is better I'm
American and I love American barbecue
and you are wrong and it's okay for us
to have different opinions and think
that each other are wrong that's what
opinions I agree with you Hank I just
want to add one thing which is that
right now what barbecue is all that we
have okay
Australia so don't take away the one
fricking thing that we still have okay
we have really good barbecue we don't
have a great health care system I
wouldn't say that our our politics are
functioning a-plus-plus right now I also
wouldn't say Australia's politics are
functioning a-plus-plus but we have this
barbecue and don't take it away from us
okay that's it I'm moving on we also got
a correction from a bunch of people in
Portland or in Seattle or any other MLS
City criticizing my making fun of MLS
which I wasn't really doing but they are
many people in Portland wanted me to
point out that the Portland Timbers were
not formed in 2009 or whatever I said
they were formed they were formed in
1975 although they've been out of
business like 72 times in the
intervening 40 years and the existing
Portland Timbers were formed in 2001 and
I want to apologize for claiming that
your 14 year old Club was only eight
years old
biron God I am the most ungrateful
corrector also Byron wanted to point out
that there is a border collie that works
at Cherry Capital Airport and this
border collie does not appear to catch
birds that are inside though I've gone
to his Instagram page then it is a very
good Instagram page just just fantastic
dog shots it appears it's Airport kay
number nine is the is the Instagram for
this dog at the cherry Capitol area yeah
the dogs named Piper I believe in Piper
it appears I think clears the runways of
of birds that might I don't know maybe
not
I can't tell wildlife control K nine do
you know where cherry capital Airport is
Hank no idea John I assume it's in DC
because it's in Traverse City Michigan
well I don't finally feel like this is a
huge Airport
feeling to say that it's not a huge
airport is a pretty significant
understatement so just for a little car
Oh actually you know they they have like
they've had like 20 or 25 flights land
just today from Detroit Chicago and
Minneapolis they're doing okay on
Traverse City yeah
yeah all right one other thing that
we've got to get to if you don't mind oh
man I'm ready this is from Lou Creek
lucrezia good Creek I'm so bad at names
Lucretia what is it look about you Oh
rosianna just pronounced it correctly
it's Lucrezia Lou crazy yeah I mean
Rosie Anna speaks Spanish which is a
huge advantage in this situation okay
I'm moving on maybe we'll just edit in
Rosie on his pronunciation beard Dear
John and Hank I am a climate scientist
and would like to assuage some concerns
raised in your most recent episode while
probably also adding some new ones
Oh climate scientists always a swaging
one concern only to add a new one there
was a question about ancient bacteria
thawing and causing epidemics as the ice
caps melt and while you did correctly
cite the concern of anthrax and reindeer
frozen in the permafrost becoming a
health issue honestly this isn't even
one of the biggest problems one of the
reasons for this is that the high
latitudes tend to be less densely
populated than the tropics or temperate
zones and so epidemics don't spread is
faster or in fact as many people another
is that there are so many other things
to worry about
for example the comfortable living range
of malaria carrying mosquitoes is likely
to spread to higher latitudes as
temperatures in those areas increase
resulting in greater incidence of
infection and floods caused by melting
glaciers and rising sea levels will
potentially spread waterborne diseases
like cholera and dysentery so if you
want to worry about climate change
related diseases you should probably
start with those and I do John I do want
to worry about climate change related
diseases and I am should add that and
that's why I should add that the
lucrezia signed off eat and be merry for
tomorrow we die oh no not in Montana
because we're pretty far out of the
range of both sea level rises and and
also the comfortable range of malaria
carrying mosquitoes so
everybody just come out here and raise
up our property values we got lots of
new rental apartments it's it's crazy
right now
John you had some bad news from AFC
Wimbledon for me I do I do
Hank I have actually incredibly exciting
news from AFC Wimbledon oh good well
it's been thigh him so hopefully
something happened I am as you know
deeply concerned about AFC Wimbledon
season as I think at this point a lot of
AFC Wimbledon fans are just because
we've lost a lot of players without
acquiring any new ones and we also don't
have very much money and it's a it's
hard to be a tie it's hard to it's just
hard to survive in league one when you
don't have any money and you're owned by
your fans so anyway there is however
good news on I would argue good news on
multiple levels which is that AFC
Wimbledon fans not living in the United
Kingdom which is to say you me and the
vast majority of the people listening to
this podcast will be able to watch live
streamed AFC Wimbledon games live inside
their internet for a fee that they pay
to AFC Wimbledon that AFC Wimbledon will
then hopefully use to buy some players
unfortunately you can't do that until
you start playing some games right well
the game starts soon but you should go
to the AFC Wimbledon website to check it
out also the the the games have been
released the the list of games you know
the like schedule that's what it's
called but with the list of games the
traditional listing of the games AFC
Wimbledon's first game is on August 5th
against Scunthorpe I mean it's always
it's always a wonderful day when you get
to visit Scunthorpe and then then they
play Brentford Shrewsbury and Fleetwood
and Doncaster and barn it all in August
so it's gonna be a big August for us and
then the sort of you know the the
matches that everyone looks to September
22nd playing against the franchise that
currently applies it's trade in Milton
Keynes and Portsmouth one of the biggest
clubs in Ligue 1 on September 9th so
it's about to start Hank the season
starts on August 5th
Scunthorpe I'm very nervous I'm not
gonna lie I'm not going to pretend I'm
not nervous I'm extremely nervous
I also nervous for you it does seem a
little bit like there aren't gonna be
enough players well today we're still
there and there are technically enough
players Hank we've already played a
couple of of preseason matches and we
did have 11 people on the pitch yeah
that's good to hear I yeah is there
something you did did they do something
wrong like how is there money left over
to get more people it's not clear the I
mean it's still the the trading signing
window is still open until the end of
August so there's still time I it's it
was always it's always going to be hard
the second season you know in in a new
league is traditionally harder than the
first season and I think part of the
problem is that it's impossible to tell
players like Jake Reeves or Tom Elliott
like you can't go play for a bigger club
that has more money because like of
course you want those players to have
those opportunities and then they just
become very hard to to replace one last
thing Hank
nerdfighteria is sponsoring AFC
Wimbledon's match against Blackpool this
season so I don't know if I'm gonna be
there for that game but a bunch of
nerdfighters will so put it on your
calendars if you're in the neighborhood
I'm definitely gonna go to a few games
this season though I'm excited well in
the news from Mars John I know that you
know that there's some weird things
about Mars so so three weird things up
with Mars we've got we've got a weird
geology where where one hemisphere of
the planet is it has way more craters
than the other the it's really like
smooth and the the north and created in
the south I've also got a weird
composition of the planet so lots of
metals in the crust very different from
Earth's composition and then you've got
these two weird lumpy moons Phobos and
Deimos and there are lots of guesses as
to
like how these three things happened and
why with with with with like different
different guesses for each one but and
one of the big ones has always been that
there was there's it's not like an early
point in Mars's history there was a how
they explained the the fact that the
northern hemisphere is so smooth is that
there was a very large impact like the
kind of impact that that earth
experienced at that time that formed our
Moon but maybe not as big as that or
maybe it just didn't do the same same
thing that ours did because Mars is
smaller or the impact was larger
whatever but a new paper came out a
couple weeks ago while we were on our
little hiatus that sort of explains all
three of those things at once which is
that this impact could have come from a
certain type of body in the early solar
system that was metal rich and very
large like the size of Ceres which is
the by far the largest object in the
asteroid belt basically a like a little
planet and and that that deposited a
bunch of of these iron loving metals
like heavy things like iridium and gold
and iron into the crust and it also like
created this much smoother area of the
planet and also shot off both Phobos and
Deimos which became Mars's moons they
these moons would not have formed in the
which might explain why they're small
and why they're sort of like lumpy
potato shaped rather than being
spherical because they weren't big
enough or warm enough to actually turn
into spheres in space so that new paper
is out now it's called colossal impact
enriched Mars's mantle with noble metals
published in June of 2017
and they're they're estimating that the
time of the the impact was about 400 4.4
billion years ago and the object was
about 1,200 kilometers in diameter
which is a biggie that's a biggie John
it's really nice that we live at a time
when the solar system has fewer of those
kinds of things floating around those up
those 1,200 kilometer objects you don't
really
want one of those around Hank a couple
questions first off are you saying that
there is gold on Mars and lots of it
hey that is that is the truth that is a
thing okay I but but John if we're gonna
mind gold from someplace it's the first
step is probably not going to be at the
bottom of the gravity well if we'll
probably pick it off of asteroids where
there are several asteroids that have a
very high composition of gold just like
the one that probably crashed into Mars
and what is the gravity well gravity
well is a very large very massive object
so so that you would have to then expend
energy to get off of so dragging
dragging the gold off the planet so
there's one thing getting getting the
gold to fall back to earth which is
actually gonna take a lot of energy but
getting it to up out of Mars and then to
fall back to earth all of that would be
like twice as much energy so you just
want it to you want to want to find
something that's not at the bottom of a
gravity well if you're gonna be lug it
out
heavy heavy metals like gold and iridium
okay that's helpful
mm-hm that's very helpful second
question if I'm on the surface of Mars
can I see two moons like do I see two
moons the way I we see one moon yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is cool that is
really cool that makes me kind of want
to go to Mars just so I can get that two
moon vibe and then having like taking a
couple pictures get back on the
spaceship well also John I don't think
you want to be on a spaceship just
knowing you like well I don't like
confined spaces and I don't like social
time with other people is there a lot of
private space on spaceships or not so
much I mean the question is what do you
what do you say to your spaceship crew
mate when it's time for them to go home
please get out of my spaceship what do
you mean there's only one spaceship and
we share it one last follow-up question
on these missions to Mars will there be
private bathrooms because I feel very
strongly about not sharing bathrooms oh
man
I don't know I don't actually I don't
know how like if the bathroom on the ISS
is even a separate room oh my god so
it's basically it's basically just like
being in prison except you can float I'm
looking now I don't I don't know if
there's a door I assume there's a door
or a curtain or something oh my god that
level I'm looking right now and I am
flipping out like that level Oh God oh
my goodness gracious you know that is
just not okay a little but place for
your butt to go
yikes itty Xers well I mean I wanted to
go to space and now suddenly I don't and
I don't suspect the desire will ever
come back to me Hank we have to go we
have to go record this weekend Ryan what
did we learn today John oh well we
learned that climate science is real and
also cholera might become more of a
problem in an age of climate change we
also learned that Josh Billings is in
the public domain so be on the lookout
for Hank and John's collection of Josh
Josh billings stuff we're gonna print it
out on my printer right here staple it
together and sell for $14.99 but why
spend 14.99 on that when you could spend
probably less than $14.99 at probably
son turtles com2 get a probably signed
pre-order of my new book turtles all the
way down on out on October 10th website
designed by Squarespace squarespace.com
slash Dear John oh that was hard to get
into a single breath and lastly we
learned that when it's time to say
goodbye to your friends you can let them
know by just saying get out get out
thanks John for being with me here on
this 100th episode up to your anchor
John I know that when I started out by
saying it was like a spectacular and it
was a fan
to fill that that like maybe you thought
we were gonna have a bunch of special
guests or something no no no no no no no
all we had with sponsors just is just
the same except I I'm like all 99
previous episodes of dear Hank and John
we now are brought to you by Squarespace
hey thanks for a squarespace.com slash
dear Hank Dear John today's podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
chairs and Gibson our editors Nicholas
Jenkins Victoria sponge genres our head
of community and communications our
music is by the great gunnarolla you can
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
or find us on Twitter where I'm John
Green and Hank is Hank green thanks
again to everyone for listening and
especially to those of you who have
listened to all 100 episodes of this
ridiculousness we really appreciate it
and it's one of the great joys in our
professional lives so thank you and as
we say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]